hi this is dungeon
I have no opening plan for that at all
could you tell okay I'm just like I just
hope something will come of this and
nothing my brain went dead but how can
it not after seeing something as strange
as this one uh I really liked it though
it's about as basic as it gets there's
there's so well that they're supposed to
warning signs around reminds me of that
Simpsons episode where it doesn't where
they end my putting the caution sign by
the wells and nobody falls out but you
don't see that one not a Simpsons fan
said I stopped watching after season
three no no no this was in seasons that
the way your Bart fee falls down oh yeah
he faked like you did and then he ended
up actually falling down there yes
season four is not bad after that I can
see where someone would yeah but I kind
of grew up a bit yeah but then I watch
Adventure Time yeah what wait a minute
so you can so Simpsons goes too far free
but Adventure Time that's the good even
ground huh and once it became the Homer
Simpson show I got kinda yeah and now
I'm kind of with dunker on time
Simpson V logs okay okay help help with
those and I visited beer for 30-some odd
years now that we'd have to go in the
later episodes that early don't want to
look ok but dungeon just see the last
Halloween episode this year it was awful
oh I stopped like ham believe okay okay
done
so we got no okay so the Simpsons was
really really good and then it hit just
this marker was like stopped me about
Bart and how he was like the kid and the
troublemaker and also in turns the home
were going Doh and more you know ya know
and then he just got too dumb to fucking
dungeon okay we're talking about dungeon
it's like I don't think it's good
episode two it is a good episode I liked
it a lot because it reminds me of those
old of like The Legend of Zelda and how
you had to sort of go and get keys and
go into different rooms and fight
different monsters and stuff
and it has a lesson in there you know
you know you're gonna figure it out that
oh they can't be without one another but
what I like is that it's obvious why
Finn would need Jake as do anything but
I like how they show why Jake needs Finn
too because it's stuff like how far can
you spit or something like shed or
sandwich yeah you know or which awesome
weapon to choose or which just the laser
pointer he couldn't stay away from so I
like this show stuff you wouldn't think
of that thing could actually help him
out with um and oh how good designs in
this one that that demon cat them
especially the initial tongue where it's
the cute face the hands upside down oh
yeah the tongue is a cute cap coming out
of a demon cat like that that's so cool
bad I love like a little party arm will
be missing but can still walk I love the
joke about how he almost is exactly
right about everything you know what'd
he call him Frank you almost know my
name I know exactly where you might be
I love how those one adjust the word
almost or might make a world of
difference so I love that they I love
the design of that bucket
was it the hook at night yeah was that
yeah I love that and yeah just something
about this one had a real good energy
real good like even though it's in sir
this dungeon dark area like still the
colors are really nice or a lot of like
yes or turquoise and yes and grays and
stuff and they still really popped um I
like the fact that bubblegum actually
does something in this episode like it I
should say that actually does stuff but
like saves the day in this one which I
like and she's like legitimately pissed
too
oh and I was like the fact too that the
voice actors in this well like we were
just talking about DiMaggio as his name
yes yeah how we're talking about before
like you know like he's fine but you
know there's not usually that much a
variety of his voices I was hearing it
in this one though like you know oh yeah
so I goodies with the sandwich and stuff
like that I want to say this I do look
at the posts that people put he
a lot of stuff like I am a huge fan of
like Final Fantasy 10 I had no idea
whose Kumari and waka that surprised me
in that to me actually is like wow I was
completely wrong like he actually can do
other things that I never would have
guessed
okay I didn't know that I didn't know he
was in the Final Fantasy and they all
definitely a lot more the fan base two
away as such a following um and is
something I I should have known about
surprise I did was I forget his name but
he was a bad guy in Kim Possible uh I
the main bad guy yeah but you know it's
but he plays that bill and I always
loved where he answer like this you know
sir the scratchy voice but at the same
time just nothing goes right nothing
goes his way and he's constantly angry
and he I don't know I
I love villains like then he played it
really well so again we've nothing
against the guy and the people have
posted a lot of stuff that's like oh he
was that I didn't know that so good job
good job a man but well but with that
say if you did a good in this one too i
yeah yeah yes sir I'm like and then the
one who ever does a Bubblegum's voice
same thing at the it was the line she
hit at the end you're done right uh yeah
yeah it's like it sound like a totally
different printer you only get one
really deep and it got a good laugh um
and yeah just the more and more I see
this world the more it seems very sort
of 8-bit video game ish and I really
like that because they feels like he has
sort of the same spirit of those video
games as well and as we're - by the time
this comes out they'll know the
editorial into idea tutorial on the most
of the Nintendo Power Mario comics it
sounds really weird no but they're
actually really good they're like
surprisingly really good because it has
sort of this similar sense of humor hey
did you read them growing up
alright there it sounds bad but they're
surprisingly funny and they're and it's
a a good story and it's not quite as
strange as this but sort of the same
thing like that
upbeat energy and just that just that
fun adventure and the bright colors and
stuff so it's uh it just remind me a lot
of that so I I really liked it what do
you got that I'm actually one thing that
I really like about this one is
how dark there were if you see like
parts in this where the demon cat
literally says I'm gonna take off your
skin and wear it yeah
and then of course the angel that saves
them which I you bring up the design I
love the design of how she is in the
beginning and then when it's it's not to
slow dissolve into this evil pace it's
just oh the boom just evil demon face
and talking about slowly you know with
the little fire and just like some
really dark comments about like killing
things off and the way they're gonna do
it and even when she's like you know
it's like how Jake was here he's saved
me and she's just like I'll save you
it's like not even that funny it's just
mean yeah he's just like you hurt sick
she is it's just a sick thing to say
give the sign of funny it's just cruel
yeah and then when Jake or Finn gets the
idea to like to care it and you start
hearing the music getting played like
playing like this dude music and then
you see it's the angel playing the
xylophone one thing it's like I had a
feeling that's what it was but I wasn't
sure so okay so it's the music's rising
you see is that you her play yeah okay
that makes a little bit more sense um
that makes sense that she's playing the
xylophone for absolutely amazing know it
there is a touch of a reason it's for
dramatic impact as the cages fine but
she's not aware of that yes so if both
makes total sense and no sense
whatsoever at the same time and that is
Adventure Time in a nutshell I think you
could argue speaking of nuts wow that's
really funny
Hey look what I have do you want some
nuts yes wow these peas look like
there's shit it out of something that's
do not look I wonder give it a little
but mmm no it's good I feel well one
other thing I'll say before we sign off
here well meeting your nuts is that
the scene where Finn is getting like I
it wasn't the fucking night it is
beating him it's like I know brutal and
I was actually sort of feeling bad huh
like I'm actually feel really bad that
Finn's getting this hurt I mean is it's
not bloody but you see the bruises you
see his face get
like you know sir puffed up and
everything and I do feel legitimately
bad as the first time I'm like wow I I
hope it stops hurting like in most cases
I'm like yeah right if again erm again
getting those funny faces done YK I feel
really bad and it's it I guess I'm a
more effective with the hes are longing
for Jake again and stuff but yeah I was
angry not shocked to help violin it was
I guess more shocked at how much I was
actually involved in not wanting to see
him get hurt and I guess that's that's a
good sign of a show Oh
Jory's phone's going off again Oh damnit
Jory I'm just gonna look at my phone
haha I push a button on it to show you
what you should have done you know this
is completely unprofessional yeah bye